Bronte: Good afternoon.
It is my pleasure to introduce Mr. Richard
Brookhiser, a graduate of Yale University.
Mr. Brookhiser is senior editor for National
Review where he has worked since 1977.
He has written for numerous other publications
including The New York Observer and the The
Atlantic.
He is also the biographer and historian of
the Founding Period, and the author of several
books including Rediscovering George Washington,
and most recently, Founders' Son: A Life of
Abraham Lincoln.
He was awarded in 2008 the National Medal
of the Humanities, and in 2011 he received
a Guggenheim fellowship.
Please join me in welcoming Mr. Richard Brookhiser.
Richard: Thank you.
Thank you, Bronte.
Thank you, Matt.
Thank you all for coming out here in this,
I guess, typical south central Michigan winter
day.
I'm very pleased to be back at Hillsdale.
This is my fourth time here.
It's always good to be here and good to see
so many old friends, but particularly for
a journalism conference, my old friend and
colleague, Professor John Miller.
Are there students of his here in the journalism
program?
Yes, okay.
Be like him and you'll do fine.
That's my tip.
I'm going to talk this afternoon about journalism
and the Founding Era.
Journalism can do a lot for good and for ill,
and in Founding Era America they sought all.
I'm going to talk about four journalists who
illustrate four aspects of journalism.
Those aspects are attacking, amusing, instructing,
and inspiring.
The four journalists who show these qualities
are James Callender, attack; Benjamin Franklin,
amusement; Alexander Hamilton, instruction;
and Thomas Payne, inspiration.
Before I get to my journalists, I just have
to explain a little bit about the world in
which they operated.
When we're talking about 18th century journalism
we're talking about print.
Telegraphs and photographs were not developed
until the 1840s, and obviously everything
wireless is 20th century.
The 18th century does have print.
It has newspapers, and it also has pamphlets
which are freestanding articles, cheaper to
produce than books.
You could think of them as magazine assays
without the magazine, although some of them
can be quite lengthy.
America in the 18th century had an usually
high number of newspapers.
I'm not going to give you an exact figure
because the figure keeps growing throughout
the period, but think in terms of several
dozen and constantly expanding.
The interesting figure is the contrast with
other countries.
American has more newspapers per capita in
the 18th century than Britain and many more
per capita than France even though Britain
and France are the two super powers in the
world and we are a small provincial ex-colonial
country.
How did we get so many of them?
Part of it's geography.
Our population is small, but it's very spread
out.
It's strung out along the east coast, and
then it begins to move into the interior.
There's no equivalent to London or Paris.
No metropolis that sucks people into it.
The population is disbursed, and therefore
the newspapers are disbursed.
His population is also surprisingly literate.
The ultimate reason for that is probably religious.
There were a number of churches in colonial
America which were very keen on Bible reading.
If people were educated to be able to read
a Bible they were also able to read a newspaper,
so there was a large potential audience there.
The founding fathers were very aware of this
media world.
A number of them were part-time or full-time
professional journalists.
Sam Adams published a newspaper.
Benjamin Franklin for much of his life was
a printer who published several different
newspaper.
At the end of his life, Alexander Hamilton
founds and publishes a newspaper, The New
York Evening Post, which is still around as
The New York Post.
Thomas Jefferson and James Madison when Jefferson
was secretary of state and Madison was a congressman,
they start a newspaper in Philadelphia which
is the nation's capital.
Neither Jefferson nor Madison actually edits
the paper, but Madison finds a man to edit
it, and Jefferson gives him a part-time job
in the State Department to guarantee his income
so it'll be easier for him to bring out this
newspaper that they want to get up and running.
Almost all the founding fathers write for
newspaper or write pamphlets at one time or
another, and all of them read newspapers.
One visitor to Mount Vernon noticed that George
Washington had subscriptions to 10 newspapers.
These men are very aware of this world, very
involved in it.
One other point about it is that all the newspapers
have a point of view.
They all express some sort of partisan opinion
and no one is bothered by that.
They will disagree with that point of view,
but no one thinks wouldn't it be nice if they're
all objective.
That's just not a goal.
You want your newspaper to be informative
because that makes it more interesting and
more useful, but everybody expects every newspaper
to be expressing a particular point of view.
That is the world.
That's the journalism.
James Callender enters this world from Scotland.
He starts off as a young man in Scotland writing
radical pamphlets after the beginning of the
French Revolution in 1789.
This causes a ferment throughout the Atlantic
world, and Britain very soon cracks down on
it because they don't want revolutionary ideas
spreading to Britain.
Callender decides in the early 1790s it would
be better and safer for him to move to the
United States.
He moves to Philadelphia where he reports
on debates in Congress.
There he meets the Clerk of the House who's
a man named John Beckley.
Now at this time, the early 17902, America
is developing its first two-party system which
will be the Federalist of Alexander Hamilton
versus the Republicans of Jefferson and Madison.
The Republicans would later become the Democrats,
the Democratic Party of today, the Modern
Republican Party has nothing to do with either
of these parties.
When we think of the disputes that Hamilton
on the one hand had with Jefferson and Madison,
we think of it as a battle of titans, of founding
fathers disagreeing about financial policy,
about the French Revolution, about the size
and structure of government.
That's true.
Below these great men there was a sub-world,
almost and underworld, of assistants, helpers,
gossips, snoops, errand boys, journalists.
John Beckley is part of that world.
He works for Jefferson and Madison, and he
spots Callender as a recruit for their side.
Callender's first great scoop happens in 1797.
He writes a pamphlet called A History of the
United States for the year 1796.
I wish I could quote from it, but it's impossible
because no copies of it exist.
It was ferocious attack on Alexander Hamilton,
and it seems as if Hamilton and his family
bought up every copy they could find, so none
are now left.
It made a big splash when it came out because
Callender made the charge that Hamilton, he
was now retired, but he was Treasury Secretary
he was engaged in insider trading with a small-time
crook named James Reynolds.
Hamilton would tip him off about Treasury
policies before they were announced.
Reynolds would go out and make trades, and
Hamilton paid Reynolds for these services.
In order to defend himself, Hamilton wrote
a 95-page pamphlet called Observations on
Certain Documents where he admitted that he
knew James Reynolds.
He admitted that he had given Reynolds $1,000
during one year when he was Treasury Secretary,
but the reason he paid him was not because
of insider trading but because he was having
an affair with Maria Reynolds, James' wife,
and James Reynolds had blackmailed him.
To prove this, he printed Maria's love letters,
James' blackmail letters, and an affidavit
from Maria's former landlord who remembered
her complaining to him that her husband wanted
to pimp her to prominent men, and Hamilton
was the man they caught.
This obviously created a sensation.
It thrilled Hamilton's enemies.
It mortified his allies.
He protected his reputation for financial
integrity.
His reputation for common sense suffered.
After this, Callender kept writing.
He got in various scrapes.
Then, in 1800, Thomas Jefferson wins a presidential
election.
He had run against John Adams in 1796 and
lost, but in the election of 1800 the Republican
party beats the Federalist party for the presidency,
and it also takes both Houses of Congress.
It is a Republican sweep.
Now James Callender thinks he should be rewarded.
He asked his friends and patrons, Jefferson
and Madison, if he could be a postmaster somewhere.
It seems as if Jefferson had become suspicious
of Callender.
It's not clear, but it is clear that Callender
did not get a postmastership.
This was a mistake because Callender moved
to Richmond, switched parties, and opened
a Federalist newspaper called The Richmond
Corridor.
There, he made his second scoop, which I will
be able to read to you from, and you've all
heard of it.
You all know of this, though you may not know
the specifics.
Here's how the story began.
This is September 1802.
"It is well known that the man whom it delighth
the people to honor keeps and for many years
past has kept as his concubine one of his
own slaves.
Her name is Sally," Sally Hemings.
"The name of her eldest son is Tom.
His features are said to bear a striking,
though sable, resemblance to those of the
president himself," and it goes on and on.
I just want to comment on that opening.
Now is this garbage.
This is characteristic assassination and politics
of personal destruction, but it is well written.
You have to understand this is well written.
First, there's the Biblical allusion, whom
it delighth the people to honor.
Everyone who read that would know that this
is a reference to the book os Esther which
is commemorated in the Jewish holiday of Purim.
The book of Esther is about Jews in captivity
in Persia.
The king of Persia has a Jewish advisor named
Mordecai, and Mordecai's adopted daughter,
Esther, is one of the king's consorts.
The king has another advisor, Haman the Agagite,
who hates Mordecai and wants to destroy all
the Jews.
The king finds out about this, and he plays
a trick on Haman.
He summons him and asks him what is the proper
reward for a man whom the king delighth to
honor, this is the source of Callender's reference.
Haman thinks he's talking himself, so he suggests
all sorts of nice things, and then the king
reveals that he's actually thinking of Mordecai.
Haman realizes that the wheel has turned,
and he is ultimately executed, and the Jews
are given permission to kill all his supporters.
What Callender is doing here, America doesn't
have king, but it does have the people, and
the people have just elected Jefferson president,
so he's the man whom it delighth people to
honor.
What Callender is suggesting is after I get
done with him he will be like Haman.
Then, he goes on, and we have this wonderful
choice of words in this sentence where he
says that Sally's son, Tom, has a sable resemblance
to Jefferson.
He could've said dark, which would've been
good because that would associate Jefferson
with darkness, but he says sable.
That gives this sentence wonderful alliteration.
Listen to all these S'es.
His features are said to bear striking, though
sable, resemblance to those of the president
himself.
It's like a hissing snake.
This is well done stuff.
Then, the rest of the piece, it rambles it
bit, and then finally Callender gets back
in his stride at the very end.
He says, "The allegations of a nature too
black to be suffered to remain in suspense.
We should be glad to hear of its refutation."
Federalists were delighted with this story.
They reprinted it.
They wrote poems about it.
They drew cartoons about it.
One famous cartoon shows Jefferson and Sally
Hemings as a pair of chickens.
Jefferson is the rooster, and the cartoon
is captioned a philosophic cock.
They played rough in the 18th century.
They really took the gloves off.
Another audience for the story a little later
is Abolitionists.
They tell the story to show that slavery is
such a wicked system that even the author
of the Declaration of Independence, which
they revere, is caught in its toils and behaves
badly.
Then, a third audience who loved the story
were Englishmen, especially Englishmen visiting
American and who were constantly told by Americans,
"Isn't this a great Democratic country, unlike
you with all your kinds, and lords, and so
on."
They liked using this story to turn it back
on Americans.
Charles Dickens and the Irish poet, Thomas
Moore, both wrote about Jefferson dreaming
of freedom in his slave's embrace.
The story is still with us.
When recent DNA tests showed that descendents
of Sally Hemings had a chromosome which is
carried on the Jefferson male line.
That's not 100% proof, but I think the burden
of proof does rest now with those would say
that the story is false.
We know about it not because of historians
or not even because of high-end classy journalists,
but because of this attack journalist, James
Callender.
For amusement, the founding father who we
rightly think as most amusing is Benjamin
Franklin.
Franklin could command many tones of voice.
He could be the scientist.
He could be giver of good advice, early to
bed or early to rise makes a man healthy,
wealthy and wise.
He had dozens of other sayings that he printed
in almanacs that we all know.
We've seem to grow up knowing them.
Franklin's maybe his best most effective voice
is humor, particularly in hoaxes. Franklin
loves to print hoaxes, pretended essays pretended
as letters by people.
He's the master of the straight face because
a hoax has to be done exactly right.
If you push it too hard it's too much.
If you don't catch the exact tone of what
you're imitating it won't work.
The very last piece of journalism that Franklin
writes when he's an old man, almost 84 years
old, is a hoax.
It's his last hoax, and it's about slavery
and the slave trade.
The Constitution, which has just gone into
effect in 1789, said that the slave trade
could not be forbidden before 1808.
This was the price of Georgia and South and
North Carolina signing.
That's in the Constitution, and the Constitution
also said this provision may not be amended,
so that was a firm deal that had been made.
Nevertheless, Quakers submitted a petition
to the first Congress asking that the slave
trade be ended.
The Quaker religion had decided earlier in
the century that slavery was something no
Christian could participate in and many Quakers
had become early abolitionists.
They submitted a petition to Congress, and
they called the Constitutional Prohibition
a seeming impediment.
Congress, obviously, has to reject their petition.
They don't have the power to accept it.
One of the speeches on it is by representative
James Jackson of Georgia.
He had some to this country when he was 15
years old in 1772.
He'd fought in the Revolution, and now he
was a congressman.
He criticizes the Quaker petition not just
on the grounds of its unconstitutionality,
but he comes very close, no, he actually he
crosses the line.
He defends slavery itself.
This is what he said in Congress, "Why do
these men set themselves up in such a particular
manner against slavery?
Do they understand the rights of mankind and
the disposition of providence better than
others?
If they were to consult the Bible they will
find that slavery is not only allowed but
commended.
If they fully examine the subject they will
find that slavery has been no novel doctrine
since the days of Cain."
This was all Franklin needed to get going.
He wrote a letter to a Philadephia newspaper.
It begins this way, it's not obviously signed
Ben Franklin, it's signed Historicus, historian
in Latin.
"To the editor of the Federal Gazette, sir,
reading last night in your excellent paper
the speech of Mr. Jackson in Congress against
meddling with the affair of slavery it put
me in mind of a similar one made about 100
years since by Sidi Mohamed I brahim, a member
of the Diwan of Algiers which may be seen
in Martin's Account of His Consulship published
in 1687.
It was against granting petition for the abolition
of piracy and slavery as being unjust.
Mr. Jackson does not quote it, perhaps he
has not seen it.
If, therefore, some of its reasonings to be
found in his eloquent speech it may only show
that men's interests operate with surprising
similarly in all countries and climates whenever
they are under similar circumstances.
The African speech is translated is as follows:…"
Before I get to the African speech, a couple
of points.
First the tone.
You all recognize the tone of this.
This is a slightly pompous letter to the editor.
We've all read those letters, maybe we've
written some of them.
Here, he writes, he has a historical comparison,
he has the name, he has a book that you can
look up.
He says, yes, he gives the book.
It's Martin's Account of His Consulship, so
evidently Martin, it sounds like an Englishman,
an English diplomat who would've been a counsel
to Algiers, and he wrote this book in the
17th century.
After this letter was published, people went
to bookstores in Philadephia asking for Martin's
Account of His Consulship.
They didn't have much luck since there is
no such book.
Then, Franklin goes on.
He says, "Mr. Jackson does not quote it, perhaps
he has not seen it."
Of course, he hasn't seen it.
Benjamin Franklin is making it all up.
Then, finally, he says, "The African's speech
as translated is as follows."
Of course, that's a very subtle dig because
Algiers is northern African, so that is Africa,
but sub-Saharan Africa is where all the slaves
of Georgia and of representative Jackson come
from.
He's kind of slyly equating Jackson's arguments
with African arguments.
Here's the speech that he quotes.
:The African speech as translated is as follows:
Allah Smallah, God is great and Mohammed is
his prophet.
How grossly are they mistaken in imagining
slavery to be disallowed by the al-Koran.
Are not the two precepts, masters treat your
slaves with kindness, slaves serve with your
masters with cheerfulness and fidelity, clear
proofs to the contrary?
Nor can the plundering of infidels be in that
sacred book forbidden since it is well known
from it that God has given the world and that
it contains to his faithful Musselmen who
are to enjoy it of right as fast they can
conquer it.
Let us then hear no more of this detestable
proposition."
Franklin is not just drawing any comparison
from any part of the world here.
He's talking about Algiers in the 17th century.
Algiers is one of the Barbary states.
These were four countries in north Africa,
Morocco, Algiers, Tunis, and Tripoli.
In both the 17th and 18th century and into
the 19th century these countries lived by
piracy and slavery.
The arrangement was if you paid them every
year they would leave your shipping alone.
You, meaning Christian countries of Europe.
If you didn't, they would raid your ships
and sell everyone they captured into slavery.
It was a religious extortion racket that they
ran.
This is a current problem when Franklin is
writing.
The United States would fight two wars with
the Barbary states early in the 19th century
when Jefferson was president, then when Madison
was president.
Franklin is writing 25 years before that,
so he's writing about an issue that is an
ongoing international problem.
Then, he ends, he quotes some more of this
speech and says, "The result was as Martin
tells us that the Diwan came to the resolution
let the petition be rejected and it was rejected
accordingly.
I am, sir, your constant reader and humble
servant, Historicus."
He's not just doing this to have fun.
He's doing it to try and change people's perceptions.
He's really saying if you can't see the evil
of slavery here because it's ours and it's
so close to us, then look at it over there
where the slaves are Christian white men,
then maybe you'll see the evil of it there.
I don't know that it had any effect on representative
Jackson, but it did raise a laugh when it
was printed in Philadelphia.
For instruction, if we think of the founding
fathers in instruction we have to think of
Alexander Hamilton because he is the great
know-it-all of the founding fathers.
He not only believed that he was one of the
only people in the country who understood
modern finance and economics, he was probably
right about that.
He also believed that he understood everything
else, and he would be happy to tell you what
he understood and how you could do your job
probably better than you were doing.
I think this is one of the personal sources
of the first two-party system.
It was about ideology.
It was about issues, but frankly, Hamilton's
personality had a lot to do with it because
some people appreciated his omniscience and
other people really disliked it including
Thomas Jefferson.
Hamilton was a journalist all his life.
His first piece was written when he was 14
years old living in the Caribbean which is
where he came from.
A terrible hurricane hit St. Croix which was
where he was living at the time.
He described it in a letter to his father,
and then it was published in a St. Croix newspaper.
After it came out, two local figures decided
this is a bright young man we have to send
him to the mainland to be educated.
Hamilton was in effect an orphan at the time
because his mother had died, although he was
writing his father, his father had taken off,
abandoned his family, just move elsewhere.
The men who helped him were his boss, Hamilton
was a clerk in a counting house, and a local
minister.
The plan was to send him to the 13 colonies.
He would become educated, and then he'd come
back to the islands as a doctor.
The first plan was to send him to Princeton.
That didn't work out, so he ended up going
to King's College which is now Columbia.
He never graduated because the American Revolution
started, and he quit to fight in it, and then
his career took off in the path that it would
follow.
Hamilton continued to write journalism while
he was in college, while he was a soldier,
and after the war when he starts getting into
law and into politics.
The greatest of his projects was the Federalist
papers.
The Constitution was, of course, discussed
and written in Philadelphia in the summer
of 1787.
When we think of debates over the Constitution
we often think of those debates in that hall.
That's partly because we have a detailed account
of them left by James Madison.
We have to remember that those debates were
secret.
No one except the delegates knew anything
about them until years later.
Madison's notes were not published until after
he died in 1840.
The debates over the Constitution that mattered
were not those debates but the ones that occurred
at the state ratifying conventions and in
the newspapers of the United States from the
fall of 1787 to the fall of 1788 when the
Constitution is finally ratified.
New York City, New York state, is a center
of opposition to the Constitution.
New York sent three delegates to the convention.
Hamilton was one of them, but the other two
left halfway through because they were disgusted
with what was going on.
One of them, Robert Yates, wrote a series
of anti-Constitution essays very quickly.
He signed them Brutus, and he made a number
of powerful arguments.
The first one was why is no bill of rights
in this Constitution.
He made it very subtly because he says the
Constitution does guarantee habeas corpus
and it forbids bills of attainder.
If they put that in there why didn't they
put in freedom of religion, freedom of speech,
no cruel and unusual punishments?
Why are there none of other rights?
He also makes a very power argument that republics
cannot be large.
We can't have a national Republican government
in this country because it's already too big
and his example is Rome.
Look at Rome.
Rome started as a city, but then it conquered
the whole Mediterranean, and at that point
it changed from a republic to an empires.
Republics have to be small.
Alexander Hamilton who's now back in New York,
he sees the effect that Brutus is having and
he knows the Constitution has to have a media
campaign in its support.
Being Hamilton, he gets one going.
He finds two collaborators, James Madison,
another delegate to the convention, and John
Jay, the former diplomat and spymaster who's
an older man.
There's five newspapers in New York City at
the time.
Hamilton arranges for their essays to be run
in all five of them.
He wanted to market saturation.
The essays came out at the rate of four a
week.
Some weeks there were five.
One week there were six.
These essays are each 2,000 words long.
A typical op-ed piece today is 750 words.
This was a brutal tempo.
When Madison was an old man he remembered
that when we started writing these things
we'd show our collaborators our first draft,
but it just became so rapid we couldn't do
that anymore, so each man was in it for himself.
Several times the printer's messenger would
be at someone's door while he was still finishing
up a Federalist essay.
Jay started off with four.
Then, he got sick.
Then, about two-thirds of the way through
he wrote another one, then he was injured
in a riot, so he only ended up writing five.
Madison wrote 29.
Hamilton wrote 51 for 85 essays in all.
They covered every aspect of the Constitution.
They didn't quite answer the question of the
Bill of Rights.
Hamilton wrote a rather interesting argument,
but it was not effectual.
They did demolish the argument that republics
have to be small.
Probably the most famous argument now is Madison's
where he says that in a large republic there
will be so many conflicting interests that
no one of them will overwhelm all the others.
Whereas, in a small one that would be easier
to happen.
Hamilton also made an economic argument.
He said that the 13 colonies naturally trade
with each other and profit from each other.
Jay made maybe the strongest argument of all.
He said, "If we have 13 states or three confederations
bordering each other they'll be constantly
at war, and European powers will be pitting
them against each other and there'll be standing
armies."
Madison is making an argument from politics.
Hamilton is making one from economics.
Jay made one for peace.
What I want to read you now is just from the
first paragraph of the first Federalist.
It's Hamilton.
This is about the whole project.
It's really a statement of the best of Democratic
politics.
Hamilton says, "To the people of the state
of New York, it seems to have been reserved
to the people of this country to decide the
important question whether societies of men
are really capable or not of estimating good
government from reflection and choice, or
whether they are forever destined to depend
for their political constitutions on accident
and force.
Can we have good government from reflection
and choice, or must we forever depend on accident
and force?"
He's asking you to think of history, and he'll
go on to be very specific ticking off examples,
but here he's just introducing it.
Think of history, revolutions, assassinations,
civil wars.
We could go through that again, but we can
do something different.
We can reflect, and then we can choose.
Then, he goes on.
"I frankly acknowledge to you my convictions."
That's the Hamilton note, I figured this out.
Then he says, "I will freely lay before you
the reasons on which they are founded."
That's also the Hamilton note.
He was a know-it-all, but he never said agree
with me because I say so.
He always said agree with me because here
are my reasons, I think it for this, and this,
and this.
He said, "I will tell you all my reasons.
My friends and I will write 85 essays if you
want, and when we're done you will know everything
I know."
He was a know-it-all, but he was a very generous
know-it-all.
That's the best statement in the spirit of
Democratic politics, trusting your electorate,
trusting your audience, sharing with them
what you think, what you know.
No, before I leave the Federalist papers,
of course, it had an effect in New York, probably
also in Virginia.
It was re-printed there.
Maybe one of the best judgments on it, the
Marquis de Talleyrand, who was wily French
diplomat, he had to live for two years in
the United States.
France got a little hot for him, so he took
a little sabbatical in the United States where
one of his friends was Hamilton whom he greatly
admired.
Then, when he was back in France running things
there from behind the scenes a Spanish diplomat
remarked to him that he had never read the
Federalist papers.
Talleyrand, the old fox, just said, "Read
it.
Read it."
Finally, inspiration.
The journalist who exemplifies is Thomas Payne.
Payne is another immigrant.
You will see that three of these four people
are immigrants, and I think that's because
journalism pulls for outsiders.
Payne is an Englishman.
He had a various life in England.
He was a corset maker.
He was a tax collector.
He was a privateer.
Then, in 1774, he comes to the United States
and there he finds himself as a journalist.
His first great his it s pamphlet in 1776
Common Sense.
This is an argument for American declaring
independence.
We've already been fighting Britain for eight
months, but we've done it still professing
loyalty to the king.
It's only are king's ministers we say are
fighting.
Payne writes Common Sense to say it's past
that point.
It's really past that point.
We should declare our independence.
His greatest moment comes at the end of that
year, in December of 1776.
The second half of that year was a disaster
for the American cause.
The British decided to attack New York, make
that their base.
Washington loses the battle of Long Island
in Brooklyn.
Then, the British land on Manhattan, they
drive him steadily off the island.
He loses the battle of White Plains in October.
He's left one garrison in northern Manhattan,
Fort Washington.
It's now Inwood Park.
There are 3,000 men in that fortress.
Nathaniel Greene tells Washington it can be
defended, but Greene is wrong.
The British take it and all 3,000 men.
Washington's watching this across the Hudson
River in New Jersey and one man said he wept
like a child when he saw what was happening.
The British cross the Hudson, pursued him
through New Jersey.
He was loosing soldiers.
His soldiers had no shoes, no adequate clothing.
You could follow the line of his retreat by
the blood of their footprints.
This won gloriously with the victories of
Trenton and Princeton at the end of the year,
but they didn't know that in the middle of
December.
Thomas Payne is living in Philadelphia.
He comes to the army in New Jersey to follow
it and report on its progress.
He writes and essay.
He writes it on a drumhead by campfire light,
then he goes back to Philadelphia to get it
printed.
It's called The American Crisis.
It has, I think, the best lead in the history
of journalism.
Here it is, "These are the time that try men's
souls.
The summer soldier and the sunshine patriot
will in this crisis shrink from the service
of their country, but he that stands it now
deserves the love and thanks of man and woman.
Tyranny like hell is not easily conquered,
yet we have this consolation with us that
the harder the conflict the more glorious
the triumph.
What we obtain too cheap we esteem too lightly.
It is dearness only that gives everything
it's value.
Heaven knows how to put a proper price upon
it's goods and it will strange indeed if so
celestial an article as freedom should not
be highly rated."
I don't know if Payne was thinking of Shakespeare
when he wrote that.
I think of King Harry's speech before the
Battle of Agincourt and Henry V where he says
this band, this happy band, this band of brothers
and every man that fights with this day shall
gentle his condition, shall become a gentleman.
Payne is writing the Republican equivalent
of that.
You're not going to become gentleman for doing
this.
You're going to earn the love and the thanks
of man and woman, of your neighbors, of your
peers.
I don't know what to say about this.
This is so eloquent.
I don't see how it can possibly be improved.
The peace goes on.
It doesn't maintain quite that level, how
could it, but there is another very moving
moment towards the end where Payne is talking
about a Tory, an opponent of the revolution
who's a tavern keeper in New Jersey.
He says, "He was standing at his door with
as a pretty a child in his hand, about eight
or nine years old, as I ever saw.
After speaking his mind finished with this
unfatherly expression, well, give me peace
in my day."
He's saying why are we having this revolution.
It's not worth it.
Give me peace in my day.
Then, Payne says, "A generous parent should've
said, 'If there must be trouble, let be in
my day that my child may have peace.'"
Payne is a little wrong because, of course,
children will all have their troubles, but
he's right because let's not pass ours to
our children.
If we have to fight to solve them let's do
that.
What became of these men, the journalists?
The first to die was Benjamin Franklin, 1790,
just some months after his little hoax at
representative Jackson's expense.
He was covered with honors and everybody loved
him.
The second one to die was James Callender.
Ten months after wrote about Sally Hemings,
he drowned in the James River in three feet
of water.
If you were insulted in those days by a gentleman
you could challenge him to a duel.
Dueling was illegal everywhere, but it was
never prosecuted because juries would not
convict.
Journalists were mostly not gentleman, so
you didn't challenge them to duels.
You could beat them up.
Payne had been beaten with a club a few weeks
before that by a son-in-law of James Monroe.
The coroner's jury ruled that his drowning
was accidental.
The next one to die was Alexander Hamilton
in 1804.
He did die in a duel.
He was shot and killed by the Vice-President
of the United States.
Journalism involved in it because a letter
had appeared in an upstate newspaper about
a dinner party of Federalists, and the letter
writer said there was some criticism of Vice-Present
Burr, and Hamilton said that he could give
a still more despicable opinion of him.
Hamilton and Burr had been fighting politically
for years.
They were both New Yorkers, both lawyers,
they knew each other.
Burr always seemed worse to Hamilton than
Jefferson.
I think in a funny way he trusted Jefferson.
He knew what Jefferson would do.
From his point of view most of it would be
wrong, but Jefferson was predictable.
He thought Jefferson was honest, and he thought
Jefferson was a cautious man.
From Hamilton's point of view Jefferson would
always talk a worse game than he would do.
Burr, he never trusted.
He thought there was something Napoleonic
about Burr, so there was a different edge
to the things he said about him.
Burr reads this letter in the upstate newspaper.
He asks for an explanation.
The two gentleman met a dueling ground in
New Jersey.
Hamilton shot, missed.
Burr hit Hamilton in liver and lodged in his
spine.
Took him 36 hours to die, and I've seen the
front page of the New York Post of that evening,
and there's a little box dropped in the front
page.
It's like a news flash or the crawler on a
CNN screen.
It says Hamilton injured in a duel, and the
next day he died.
The last one to die was Thomas Payne.
After our revolution, he goes to France and
gets involved in its.
He's elected to the French National Assembly
even though he hardly speaks any French.
He votes to depose Louis XVI and to set up
a republic.
He argues against executing him, and his argument
is that Louis XVI has grown up in a royal
world, what else did he ever know, we should
send him to America and he can live under
a republican government and maybe he'll improve
as a person.
This argument is not persuasive.
Payne was arrested.
He was slated to for execution.
The only reason he was not guillotined is
that they passed his cell by accident the
day he was to be killed.
Then, there's a change in the wheel of politics
and he's released.
He comes back to America in 1802.
By this time, he's drinking heavily and he
dies poor in Greenwich Village in 1809.
Journalism can do great things.
Journalists don't necessarily have great lives.
Thank you very much.
Speaker 2: We have a few minutes for questions.
We have microphones coming thoughout.
Please raise your hand and stand.
Also, please speak up and keep the question
shorter than the answer might be.
Let me also mention that right after the Q&A
session, Mr. Brookhiser has agreed to sign
copies of the Founder's Son: A Life of Abraham
Lincoln, his newest book, over here just on
this level by the staircase.
Richard: Okay, any questions?
Great, I've explained it all.
Yes, there we go.
Yes, sir.
Audience: Regarding Dr. Franklin, I've read
where he wrote a fictitious letter which was
his style, all the way from Silence Dogood,
called the Tobacco Letter in which he used
psychological warfare to convince Hessians
to desert.
So far from what I've read, this is all speculation.
I'd like your comment if indeed this was written
by Dr. Franklin or not.
It has his fingerprints all over it and to
divulge the actual author would absolutely
nullify any good that it would do as far as
the Hessians deserting.
Please …
Richard: Look, he wrote so many of these hoaxes
I cannot keep track of them.
All his works are published, so you can look
in there.
He did keep it up during the Revolution.
He was sent to France as a diplomat.
He lived outside of Paris, but he set up a
printing press in his house where he churned
out articles and some of them are humorous
pieces, but he also wrote political pieces,
a tax on British conduct and also hoaxes of
the kind you're talking about.
It certainly sounds like him.
I simply don't know, but the complete works
are out there, so not so hard to chase down.
Yes, sir.
There we go.
Audience: Sir, thank you very much for your
time today.
My question's going to be going back to your
talk about James Callender and that type of
investigative reporting.
How does that relate to contemporary press
coverage?
If you could just expand a little bit on that
from the evolution of freedom of the press
from that period in history into today's modern
era.
Thank you, sir.
Audience: I mean look, there are obvious similarities.
Callender, his two big scoops involved sex
scandals, the one he elicited from Hamilton,
and then other he simply tried to tie to Jefferson's
tail.
Heaven knows, we wallow in this stuff.
The Clinton era sort of opened the flood gates
and on and on it goes.
There is something disreputable about journalism,
there is.
It's always there, and it will never go away.
John, I hope I'm not corrupting your students,
but this is an aspect of it.
Journalists tell things that people don't
want known, although we like to read them.
A lot of those things are misbehavior.
This is just in the mix.
It's never going to disappear.
Journalists, David Brooks, he recently was
on some TV show and he talked about there's
the adult table and the kiddie table of journalism.
David's an old friend of mine.
I thought, "Oh geez, David.
Come on.
The kiddies all over the place, and somehow
adults behave like them, and sometimes the
kiddies grow up."
That's journalism and it's never going go
change it's spots entirely.
Audience: Thank you, Mr. Brookhiser.
The four aspects that you mentioned, are there
journalists today or in the recent past that
you would cite as examples as amusing, inspiring,
attacking, instructional?
Richard: I'm just going to talk about the
18th century.
Sorry.
Audience: Speaking of instructive, James Madison
certainly was in that category not only because
he collaborated with Hamilton in the Federalist,
but because he and Hamilton were writing dueling
essays in the 1790s.
Richard: Be careful how you use the word dueling.
Audience: Yeah, yeah.
Journalist dueling.
Richard: Right.
Audience: In any event, which was quite an
informative period.
Hamilton started the National Gazette.
I'm sorry, the Gazette of the United States
which John Fenn was the editor, and then Madison
and Hamilton countered with the National Gazette.
That was war going on early in the administration,
well through the Washington administrations.
I'd just like you to comment on the significance
of that.
Audience: Doris Kerns Goodwin wrote this very
good book about the Lincoln administration
which she called team of rivals.
That phrase has become like management mantra,
hasn't it?
You just see a lot.
People think of that, that's the way to run
my company.
I should get four or five people who hate
each other and completely disagree and then
it'll be great.
The first team of rivals was the Washington
administration.
It was not supposed to be that way.
No one thought it would be that way.
It only became so over time and partly because
of Hamilton's personality, partly because
the French Revolution happened.
Washington is inaugurated in April of 1789
and the Bastille falls in July.
When he's first thinking of his cabinet this
is not on his table, and then, just the issues
of setting up a government and how it should
be set up.
It was hell for all of them.
It was just hell for them.
It's a tribute to Washington's leadership
and to his skill that he kept these guys in
the same tent as long as he did.
He worked to keep Thomas Jefferson in his
job as Secretary of State long after Jefferson
had turned against the Washington admission
and was subsidizing this newspaper which attacked
the Washington administration.
Washington figured keep your enemies close,
and so he worked and worked.
Finally, Jefferson left, but it was it was
brilliant job.
He kept him on much longer than you would've
thought.
Also, this was all new.
I think one reason for the frenzy of politics
in the 1790s, some historian called it the
age of passion is that it was brand new.
Now we know if you lose you're going to have
another chance in four year or eight years.
No party is ever run out of town, but they
didn't know that because this was brand new.
They knew the Constitution they had written,
and they knew the laws that they had passed,
but you don't believe in them until you have
experience of them.
Federalists truly thought that the Republicans
might set up guillotines if they want.
The Republicans truly thought that Hamilton
was a monarchist.
Those are both nonsensical.
Thomas Jefferson was not going to set up guillotines.
He praised them in France, but he had no intention
of setting them up here.
Hamilton was not a monarchist.
He fought against a monarchy in the Revolution.
Both sides had these misapprehensions of the
other.
It's really, then of course, we did have the
Civil War in the 1860s, but it takes a lot
of experience before a country realizes that
it's unlikely that it will tear itself apart,
and it's unlikely that the winners will simply
crush the losers.
That was something.
It was even than wisdom it took and even more
than genius.
It took experience to live that lesson.
One more?
Speaker 2: We have time for one more question.
Audience: You mentioned earlier in your speech
that back then the newspapers were all clearly
biased and everybody knew that every newspaper
they read had a point of view.
What do you think about the strengths and
weaknesses of that system and how effective
it was compared to what we have today?
Richard: I kind of like it.
It's more straightforward.
The newspapers did have information.
It wasn't screeds all the time.
They would report on the shipping news, and
they'd tell you about the battles in Europe,
and they'd report the doings of Congress,
and that's also a selling point, right?
That's interesting information that's useful.
Your readers want to know it, you want to
supply it.
They did get the information out and the news
out.
Then, they had their point of view, and people
knew what it was and expected it.
I the system worked pretty well.
I think I've indicated that the lows of journalism
were lower than they are now.
They really were, but the highs were higher.
We had Thomas Payne at his best.
The Federalist papers were running as op-eds,
and I think that's a pretty good credit to
the founding era.
Okay, thank you very much.